in popular culture the term IQ is
everywhere do IQ exams do that you
probably need 120 points of IQ I don't
know what my IQ is an IQ IQ IQ low IQ
individuals people who boast about their
like newer losers
when people say IQ what they mean is
intelligence and objective rigorous
measurement of intellectual ability
but does it actually work well in this
video I want to find out where IQ came
from what does it actually measure what
can it predict about your life and I
guess what is my IQ
I have never taken an official IQ test
before honestly I don't think I'm
terribly smart I've always kind of
considered my IQ to be maybe just a
little above average exothermic or
endothermic I feel like that should be
exothermic good job Science Guy there
are a lot of IQ tests online but I am
very skeptical about their accuracy
still I figured some of them may be good
practice for the real thing tomorrow I'm
going to do an IQ test for real before I
do that I want to try to improve my
score and so I'm gonna try to do a whole
bunch of practice tests I think this
test is trainable but tomorrow we're
gonna see whether that's true or not
the idea of intelligence testing goes
back hundreds of years but the first
concrete breakthrough occurred in 1904.
English psychologist Charles Spearman
was studying students grades in
different subjects and he wondered how
their performance in one subject like
English would relate to their
performance in another like math
one option would be that the better a
student did in math the worse they would
do in English maybe because they spent
more time on their math work and so had
less time to devote to English so
performance in different subjects would
be negatively correlated
another option was that performance in
one subject would be completely
unrelated to Performance in another
after all different subjects require
different skill sets so maybe Marx would
be totally uncorrelated the third option
was that the better a student did in
math the better they would do in English
in other words their marks would be
positively correlated a correlation
coefficient can vary anywhere from
negative one to positive one a
correlation coefficient of negative one
indicates a perfect negative correlation
meaning an increase in one variable
corresponds to a precise predictable
decrease in the other variable
similarly a correlation of positive one
indicates a perfect positive correlation
a correlation of zero indicates no
relationship between the two variables
and any value between 0 and 1 indicates
a positive correlation but the data has
some random spread
the square of the correlation
coefficient tells you the amount of
variation in one variable that can be
explained by variation in the other
variable
for example if the correlation
coefficient is 0.5 then 25 percent of
the variation in one variable can be
explained by the other
when Spearman analyzed his data he found
a clear positive correlation students
who did better in math also tended to do
better in English and the correlation
coefficient was 0.64
but math and English weren't the only
subjects the student studied they also
took Classics and French and when
Spearman looked at the correlations
between all of these subjects he found
the same pattern this students who did
well in one subject tended to do well in
them all so how do you explain this
observation well Spearman proposed that
each person has some level of general
intelligence what he called the G Factor
this construct was meant to capture how
quickly students could learn new
material recognize patterns and think
critically regardless of the subject
matter which explains why students
scores across subjects are correlated
those with high G score well on all
subjects and those with low G score
poorly on all subjects Spearman
published his conclusions in a paper
titled general intelligence objectively
determined and measured
but the correlations weren't perfect so
on top of the G Factor Spearman proposed
subject-specific factors or S factors a
student's performance in math for
example would depend on their general
intelligence plus their subject-specific
factor for math
subject-specific factors could increase
or decrease performance on that
particular subject
Spearman believed that specific factors
could be trained but general
intelligence was fixed so he wanted to
find a way to reliably measure general
intelligence
at around the same time in France Alfred
Binet was tasked with figuring out which
kids needed more help in school
together with Theodore or Simone he
developed the Binet Simone test
students were asked to name what's
missing in the drawing Define abstract
terms and repeat back sentences and
there was also this question asking
which face is prettiest
there were 30 tasks in all
their performance was benchmarked
against other students of different ages
in order to assign them a mental age for
example if a student performed about as
well as the average eight-year-old their
mental age would be eight this mental
age was then divided by their actual age
and multiplied by a hundred to arrive at
a so-called intelligence quotient and IQ
was born
so the binay Simone test was the world's
first IQ test it was translated by
Goddard into English and brought to the
U.S
at Stanford Lewis Turman standardized it
using a large American sample and with
some modifications it became the
Stanford Binet test and for decades it
was the most widely used test in the
United States
but this was just the start many other
IQ tests were developed they all had the
same goal of measuring the G Factor the
way they did this was by assessing many
different mental abilities including
memory verbal spatial and numerical
skills
each one of these areas might have a
subject-specific shift but by averaging
them all together the idea was the
subject-specific effects would cancel
out leaving a decent approximation of G
of course there would always be some
error but that's why psychologists
designed IQ tests with upwards of seven
to ten sections with distinct tasks to
try to minimize subject-specific
distortions
all the different IQ tests differed in
the number of questions and their
difficulty so to standardize the scoring
system each test was given to a large
sample of the population raw scores were
normalized usually so the mean was a
hundred and the standard deviation was
15. and that's how it's still done to
this day
this is known as IQ and it's meant to be
a measure of an individual's G factor in
comparison to the rest of the population
the way it scaled 68 of people have an
IQ between 85 and 115 only around two
percent score over 130 or under 70.
11 Lions four cats and seven crows have
a total of
oh boy as I was studying for my IQ test
I practice all the different types of
questions that appear on Modern tests
one section will almost certainly be on
vocabulary they give you one word like
sanguine and you have to pick which of
the multiple choice options is most
similar in meaning is it gloomy asinine
recalcitrant optimistic or reflective
they might also ask you to pick a word
with the opposite meaning so what is the
opposite of perspicacious is it canny
obsequious dull fanciful or sagacious
another section tests your ability to
spot patterns with numbers so pick the
number that best completes the pattern
three five eight twelve what comes next
originally I was looking for complicated
patterns but as I familiarized myself
with the online tests I discovered the
patterns were usually pretty simple a
good technique is to find the difference
between adjacent terms so in this case
the first two terms are separated by two
the next by three and then four so The
Logical next term should be five more
than Twelve so 17 the answer is C
sometimes the numbers grow rapidly like
in the sequence 3 15 60 180 what comes
next in cases like this I look at the
ratio of one number to the one before it
in this case the second number is five
times the first the next number is four
times bigger and the next one is three
times larger so the answer should be two
times the fourth term which is 360.
answer B
one of the best known types of IQ test
questions are Ravens Progressive
matrices these involve a three by three
grid with symbols in each of the cells
you have to select the ninth cell which
follows the pattern I found that the
bulk of these puzzles obey one of only a
few different logical rules one is
translational motion so the symbols move
from one cell to the next in a
predictable fashion the second is
rotational motion one or several objects
rotate from one cell to the next
the third is missing symbols where in
each row or column each symbol appears
once so to figure out which symbols
appear in the final cell you just have
to spot which ones are missing and the
fourth is addition where the first cell
plus the second cell equals the third
cell in this case lines that overlap
cancel out but a line plus nothing
equals a line
in most modern IQ tests all of the
questions are completed under time
pressure you may have only around 10 to
30 seconds per question okay this
morning I'm taking an official IQ test
and I gotta say that I'm pretty nervous
I always want to do well on tests you
know it's something I pride myself on
but at the same time you know uh who
knows how this is gonna go I'm not
allowed to take you in there because
obviously if people don't want the
questions getting out and they don't
even want video of what it looks like in
their you know they're very strict about
these things so I'm going to go in do
the test I'll come out and I'll let you
know how it went wish me luck what's
remarkable about IQ tests is that an
hour or two of questions on vocabulary
numbers and arbitrary shapes can predict
a surprising amount about your life
for one thing the higher your IQ the
larger your brain is likely to be
a large meta-analysis from 2005
estimated a correlation of 0.33 between
IQ and brain size so high IQ is
literally big brain
IQ is also predictive of school Success
in 2007 Scottish psychiatrist Ian Deery
measured the IQs of 13 000 11 year olds
and five years later when these students
completed National School examinations
Deary compared their exam marks to their
IQs
their performance on an IQ test when
there were 11 correlated with their
performance five years later on the
gcses about 0.8 that's an extremely high
correlation it means about two-thirds of
the variation in national school
examination scores could be predicted by
IQ tests taken five years prior
now the correlation coefficient of this
study is at the high end of the 0.2 to
0.8 Range found in similar studies but
research supports the claim that IQ is a
good predictor of school Success it also
predicts how much schooling a person
will complete
maybe this shouldn't be so surprising
since some school tests are essentially
IQ tests it's been argued that tests
like the SAT Act and the GRE are
basically IQ tests they correlate with
standard IQ tests at around 0.8 now in
my SATs I got a score of 1330 which
corresponds to an IQ of around 130. so
it'll be interesting to see if my
official IQ score matches that or if I
was able to increase my score by
familiarizing myself with IQ style
questions
I don't know
IQ also has predictive power outside of
school one of the most robust findings
is that IQ can predict job success
particularly in technical or high
complexity jobs how do you measure
occupational success uh you ask people's
bosses to rate them you ask what
people's income is you measure
productivity in ways that economists use
about you know the output generated
the correlations typically range from
0.2 to 0.6 and the effect is most
notable for more complex jobs which
makes sense the highest effect is for
military training in fact the U.S
military will not accept anyone with an
IQ under 80.
they also limit to 20 the number of
recruits with IQs between 81 and 92.
during the Vietnam war in order to
increase the pool of applicants they
relaxed this last requirement but what
they found was that those below the
threshold were 1.5 to 3 times as likely
to fail recruit training and they
required between three to nine times as
much remedial training taken together
this added so much strain that the
military ran more efficiently without
the extra recruits in total
5478 people recruited under this
initiative died at a fatality rate three
times higher than ordinary recruits so
the military reinstated their
requirements and today anyone with an IQ
less than 80 that is about 30 million
Americans would be ineligible to join
the military
even outside the military IQ seems to
play a role in how long you live in a
Scottish study scientists uncovered IQ
tests from kids when they were 11 years
old now 65 years later they checked to
see who from the sample was still alive
at age 76 they found that on average for
every 15 Point increase on the IQ test
you would be 27 percent more likely to
still be alive at age 76. a large
meta-analysis confirms that people with
higher IQs have a lower risk of dying
during the time frame investigated in
each study
the last major thing that IQ seems to
predict is income this study shows a
clear tendency for income to increase
with IQ and it found a correlation
coefficient of 0.3 but the variance is
huge in fact the top three earners in
this study all had IQs below 100.
a large meta-analysis of 31 studies
found the correlation between IQ and
income to be 0.21 that is significant
but small it means that only 4.4 percent
of the variance in income is explained
by IQ maybe one of the reasons why we
don't see as high a correlation for
income is just because
economically intelligence is not
necessarily that highly rewarded in that
maybe there are jobs you know like uh
just doing a realist real estate type
scheme like maybe that doesn't require a
huge amount of intelligence
simultaneously you have all these very
highly intelligent people who maybe
become College professors but that
doesn't necessarily pay very well
yeah a lot of people who have very high
intelligence scores don't have the same
interest in in accumulating money the
relationship with net worth is even
weaker it hardly seems to correlate with
IQ even though people with higher IQs
are supposedly more intelligent and on
average they make more money each year
but this apparently doesn't translate
into saving or accumulating more wealth
overall
but if IQ correlates with school
achievement job performance income and
Longevity why don't we hear more about
it why aren't more people tested I think
it's because IQ has a dark history
when Henry Goddard brought binay's test
to America its use and interpretation
shifted dramatically in France binay
believed intelligence could be improved
through education he designed his tests
so that struggling students could be
given more help to catch up
but in the U.S the modified test was
given to adults
to rank them by intelligence
and researchers like Spearman believed
that g was unchangeable that whatever
general intelligence you were born with
you would have for the rest of your life
and many thought G was inherited passed
down from parents to children these days
we would say it has a genetic basis
there is some evidence to support these
assertions IQ appears fairly consistent
over one's lifetime so they had tests
done when people were 11 years old they
found all those tests in a filing
cabinet and followed those people up and
gave them the same tests when they were
90 years old you know much much later
their scores 80 years apart were
correlated at around 0.5 to 0.6
there's also evidence for a genetic
basis to IQ you find for instance that
if you get two identical twins and give
them an IQ test they have a very strong
correlation it's actually about the same
as giving the same person the test you
know a few weeks apart
Henry Goddard used the claims that
intelligence was inherited and
unchangeable to put IQ at the center of
the American Eugenics movement
eugenesis wanted to prevent those with
undesirable traits from having kids
in many states laws were passed to
enable forced sterilization of people
who failed to meet a certain threshold
on an IQ test
the constitutionality of these laws was
upheld by the Supreme Court in 1927.
even words that we now use as insoles
idiots imbecile were used as
scientific terms in his judgment Justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes wrote it is better
for all the world if instead of waiting
to execute degenerate Offspring for
crime or to let them starve for their
imbecility Society can prevent those who
are manifestly unfit from continuing
their kind three generations of
imbeciles are enough
in total over 60 000 people were
forcibly sterilized as a result of these
laws in fact they served as a model for
Nazi Germany Hitler himself claimed to
be inspired by American eugenicists
these have been used for horrific things
in the past at the Nuremberg trials
after the war some Nazis quoted from the
American Supreme Court decision
given this awful history I think it's
understandable that many people
completely disregard IQ today on the
science of intelligence there are a
number of things those early researchers
got wrong one is that IQ is not entirely
determined by genetics can you quantify
the effects of genetics versus
environment when you look at twin
studies on average across the whole
lifespan it's about 50 50 to
heritability and environment you simply
can't for ethical reasons estimated in
humans you know with a reasonable degree
of certainty or accuracy given my
reading of that literature it's a pretty
broad range probably somewhere between
40 percent and 70 percent
okay
and since education can improve IQ it is
not completely fixed over a lifetime
plus into
struct as initially imagined these days
scientists recognize two forms of
intelligence fluid and crystallized
fluid intelligence is your ability to
learn process information and solve
novel problems whereas crystallized
intelligence involves the knowledge
you've accumulated over your lifetime
both types of intelligence increase
throughout childhood but fluid
intelligence peaks in early adulthood
and then declines whereas crystallized
intelligence remains more stable
but IQ has been further misused to
promote the idea of racial differences
in intelligence there is for example an
observed gap between the average IQ of
black and white Americans
articles have also been published on the
IQs of different nations around the
world many of these nations are
purported to have average IQs below 70.
that's the cutoff for intellectual
disability how could this be
the conclusion that some draw is that
there are genetic differences between
races or nations in intelligence
but I think that's a gross
misrepresentation of the data the
problem I'd argue is that IQ tests don't
necessarily measure what you think
they're measuring and the proof is that
there's a representative sample of white
Americans whose average IQ is 70.
who are these people
just ordinary Americans who lived around
100 years ago
researcher James Flynn studied the
average results of IQ tests over the
past Century and every so often the
tests get updated and renormalized to
keep their average at a hundred now what
Flynn noticed was that each time they
got renormalized the scores had to be
shifted down a bit more by about two or
three IQ points per decade and if they
didn't do this what we would see is that
the average IQ of the whole population
was increasing at a steady rate for the
last 100 years adding up to around a 30
point increase this is known as the
Flynn effect where our immediate
ancestors on the verge of mental
retardation
because 70 is normally the score for
mental retardation or are we on the
verge of all being gifted because 130 is
the cutting line for giftedness now the
genetics of the population haven't
really changed over 100 years so what
caused the increase
well there is some debate about the true
causes but one of them is probably
improving childhood nutrition and health
you know height also increased across
that time period right people got taller
and taller and taller another cause is
better education there's lots of
evidence that school makes you more
intelligent you become better at problem
solving if you have more knowledge
because it's easier for you to make
associations if you have more things to
make the associations with
a third proposed cause is a shift in the
types of work that most people do from
Mostly manual labor 100 years ago to
much more abstract thinking these days
and that shift may have made us better
at answering the types of questions that
are asked on IQ tests
[Music]
again the point is that IQ tests appear
to objectively measure intelligence but
they don't even in the same country
separated only by time cultural changes
can affect the average scores on IQ
tests so why shouldn't we expect
cultural differences between groups at
the same time to have the same effect
some tests go so far as to label
themselves culture Fair meaning the
questions should be equally valid for
all cultures but the truth is it's
impossible to construct such a test does
that work no
okay no I mean that's just a title right
that's just a marketing term I don't
think there is such a thing as a
completely culture free or culture Fair
uh test culture Fair tests assess visual
relations geometric shapes and patterns
ignoring the fact that cultures differ
in for example whether they have words
for shapes or spatial relations these
differences influence how people think
about and use categories it's also
debatable whether cultures without
printed materials even perceive them in
the same way that we do
what culture Fair tests don't assess is
ethnobotanical knowledge or training
dogs to hunt or surviving alone in the
rainforest arguably these forms of
intelligence are more important for
survival than knowing say the next
number in the sequence but since they
are less common in our culture and we
don't have good ways of measuring them
we see IQ puzzles as the definitive way
to quantify intelligence and the people
who make these tests agree there are
stringent requirements before a test
validated for one population can be used
with a very different population
even in the limited forms of
intelligence that IQ attempts to assess
there are factors other than G which
affect the final IQ
like motivation how much someone is
incentivized to complete the test can
have a marked impact on their score many
Studies have tried paying subjects to
complete an IQ test in some studies
they're offered a little say around a
dollar other studies offer between one
dollar and ten dollars and the real high
rollers offer more than ten dollars a
large meta-analysis showed that
motivating people in this way increased
IQ and the larger the dollar amount the
greater the average increase at the high
end IQ increased by up to 20 points the
effect is largest for those with below
average IQs so in addition to G IQ tests
also measure motivation
but it doesn't stop there
they do rotate training and coaching for
an IQ test can boost scores by up to
eight points
I just completed the test in some random
notice none to really talk after that it
seemed pretty fair there were lots of
different sections the math section in
particular I feel like I killed those
questions were easy I would say having
done the test I feel like that should be
trainable like you should be able to
train someone to do that well test
taking strategy is also important some
people are just better at taking tests
under time pressure than others I think
the hardest thing about the test was the
time limits looking for the patterns in
a series of shapes and it just normally
takes me a little while and so I feel
like I didn't finish those you have to
know when to skip questions how to
eliminate clearly wrong answers and when
to guess
anxiety also plays a role apparently a
small amount of anxiety is good but past
a certain point it negatively impacts
performance
uh I guess the overall review is
I think I think I did okay and I think
the training actually really really
helped that's my prediction let us fast
forward to the future and see how I
actually did
I actually got my results from the
author of the IQ test I took those are
three areas uh three specific areas for
the math one for the numbers ones I
think that's where I felt really
comfortable and I you know got there
before the time was done and then I
could go back and look at a few things
yes uh you blew the roof off the
quantitative one on the quantitative it
was 143 it was on the crystallized
intelligence index it was 132. the fluid
intelligence index was 118.
which still is a higher score than 88
and a half percent uh if it's not it's
not bad but that's it's interesting that
that one is is uh you know significantly
lower I guess and that's not an unusual
difference around that concept of G
people have strengths and weaknesses if
we were to look at the best estimate of
G for you uh on this set of tests and
it'd be different if you took a
different test it was at 134 which uh is
higher than 98.8 percent of the
population wow
hopefully you're not disappointed with
any of that no you know I I wanted to do
well I you know I feel like my
motivation was was high possibly higher
than the the average person
so what is IQ good for my clinical
practice now is forensic neuroscience
and about 90 percent of my cases are
death penalty one of the most common
issues is what's referred to the Atkins
defense after the name of the U.S
Supreme Court case that eliminated a
death penalty for people with
intellectual disability can't the
criminal just throw the IQ test can't
they just intentionally answer every
question wrong we know that I mean we
include just like in the test that that
you took
there are embedded measures of
invalidity it's detected using various
mathematical algorithms we're better
than 95 accurate in detecting people who
are attempting to fake poor performance
oh wow
one thing that we may be interested in
doing is to boost people's cognitive
ability early in life so that it takes
them if even if they go into Columns of
decline
it takes them longer to reach the points
uh where they'll have sort of functional
actual everyday problems where they
where they lose Independence whether it
comes to you know dealing with their
money or whether it comes to dealing
with
um you know reading labels whatever it
is that that people struggle with when
they get into kind of later stages of
cognitive decline if we could discover a
way to lastingly boost people's
intelligence that would be massively
helpful maybe its best use is in
identifying individuals with strong
intellectual abilities who haven't
otherwise been able to demonstrate them
teachers would recommend that a kid gets
put in the gifted and talented program
because generally they'd observe them uh
doing well in the classroom but if you
replace that with a standardized test an
IQ test you find
um higher proportion of poorer kids and
kids from from Minority ethnic
backgrounds in the gifted in talented
program when you use an IQ test and the
reason is that you're using an objective
measure you're not just relying on some
teacher's opinion getting into a good
school was about who you knew or who
your parents knew or how much money your
parents had not so much about how you
were doing the idea that you could try
to develop an objective-ish measure that
would try and iron out all those social
biases
was clearly a well-meaning idea IQ is
something that uh not only psychology
but the general public has a love-hate
relationship with tell me about that
psychologists hate to talk about you
know intelligence and people's
intelligence test scores and that kind
of stuff and I've had Parents you know
when I've included intelligence as part
of a neuropsychological evaluation of
their kid they'll say well yeah yeah I'd
like I'd like to know his IQ but you
know we don't really care about that
what was it
and then I also think you have the
debate about IQ extremes on both sides
which I think doesn't help
um you have the extreme of people who
say this is the most important thing
ever people's IQ is the is a majorly
important factor that we must know about
them and we can classify them into
particular schools or particular ways of
Education or whatever that's a one
extreme and I think that's totally
unpredictable unproductive but there's
another extreme The Other Extreme is the
kind of blank slate view which is that
these tests are completely useless they
don't tell us anything that they're only
a tool of racism and Prejudice and so on
I think that's wrong as well and there's
just this massive Firestorm on both
sides happening around them and the
people in the middle just get just get
forgotten people have more moderate
views on these on these sort of topics
so you know I'd recommend that people
um look for the more moderate views on
this I think the big mistake is thinking
that IQ in some way determines someone's
worth
what's much more important in my opinion
is how you interact with and help the
people around you which is why I think
Stephen Hawking said people who brag
about their IQ are losers
while IQ tells us something it doesn't
tell us how our lives will turn out we
have the ability to dramatically improve
our outcomes by building knowledge and
analytical skills and if you're looking
for a free and easy way to do that then
you should check out this video sponsor
brilliant.org with brilliant you can
master key Concepts in everything from
data science and math to programming and
Technology just set your goal and
Brilliant designs the perfect learning
path for you equipping you with the
tools you need to succeed they also help
me understand how IQ and net worth are
related by creating some amazing data
visualizations want to learn how to
think like a data scientist then
brilliant's latest course exploring data
visually is a fast and easy way to get
there it requires no coding skills and
instead you'll focus on the whys behind
the data and analyze real data sets to
learn things about the world you know in
today's world data skills aren't just
nice to have they're essential brilliant
is more than just a learning platform
it's your path to understanding the
world of math data and computer science
and what's great about brilliant is that
all the lessons are Hands-On so you
build real intuition so you can put what
you've learned to good use one thing I
didn't include in the main part of the
video is that the only aspect of
Personality that correlates with IQ is
openness to experience the more you're
willing to give new things a try the
more you'll learn and the smarter you'll
be so to try everything brilliant has to
offer for free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org veritasium I will put that
link down in the description in the
first 200 of you to sign up will get 20
off Brilliance annual premium
subscription so I want to thank
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
I want to thank you for watching